[Music]
thank you to all of my supporters on
patreon we're gonna have to break
certain conventions for this one in this
video we're going to talk about how to
sound like John Cage now if you clicked
on this video expecting me to sit at the
piano for four minutes and 33 seconds
I'm glad you're watching this video
because there is so much more behind
John Cage's music then this particular
conceptual idea Cage was heavy on
experimentation and took the idea of
instrumentation to its extremes so
firstly it'll help to prepare the piano
basically what we're doing is adding
nuts bolts and rubber in between the
strings to take a piano sounding like
this to sound like this so as you can
hear this makes the piano sound rather
broken that's if you're using
traditional harmony and phrasing that is
if we now treat the piano more like a
percussion ensemble the results are
quite different attention to subtle
differences in Tambor is necessary as
well as an openness to what we perceive
and experience as music
we're going to abandon traditional
harmony chord progressions and melodic
structure yet not completely in other
words some notes will still have more
gravity over others and traditional
elements such as motivic structure form
and some amount of tonality will still
be present we're going to take notes on
the harmonies rhythms and textures found
in music from all over the world such as
Indian music gamelan music and jazz just
to name a few
the use of silence and space between the
notes is very important so there will be
a lot of room for breathing with
experimentation comes unpredictable
outcomes so it's best to embrace the
nature of chance and in determine
ability look into East and South Asian
philosophy and culture as well as nature
to find more inspiration related to this
you
so at these points in mind I then set
out to come up with my version of happy
birthday in the style of John Cage a
pattern like this that provides a threat
some sort of consistent material but
it's a little uneven and then maybe a
contrasting section
[Music]
semitones dissonant intervals tritone
[Music]
I'm trying to make use of these
percussive sounds where the pitches will
land where the melody essentially will
land always be so regular and in that
way it's applying elements of chance and
randomness and I'm embracing the
sonority here which is very
unconventional obviously a non prepared
piano would not sound like this I think
that's about it now here's the final
version
[Music]
maybe something like that
thanks so much for watching if you want
to check out my other birthday homage is
I've released previously check out the
link in the description